- [Announcer] This UCSD-TV program is
presented by University of California
Television. Like what you learn? Visit our
website or follow us on Facebook and
Twitter to keep up with
the latest programs.
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal, naked, large brained, long the
the master of fire, tools, and
language but still trying to understand
ourselves. Aware that death is inevitable,
yet, filled with optimism. We grow up
slowly. We hand down knowledge.
We  empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past.
CARTA brings together experts from diverse
disciplines to exchange insights
on who we are and how we got here.
An exploration made possible by the
generosity of humans like you.
- [Elizabeth] I particularly appreciate
being invited because I'm not a
paleoanthropologist, and I don't really
study climate specifically. Instead, what
I'm going to do is give you the
perspective of the other animals that
occupy the earth, these small animals,
large animals. And I'm going to definitely
delve us into the future and ask some
tough questions about our population. So I
title my talk somewhat provocatively about
tipping points. And tipping points are-
they're situations of a state where you
have a non-linear kind of system. And when
you move beyond some particular point in
that non-linear system, you can't go back
to where you started. Now I'm going to
advocate that we're poised on the edge of
a tipping point for planet Earth. So, when
some threshold is crossed, and the
question is are we about ready to cross it
or have we already? This system is going
to move into a new state. And the example
I put up here is an egg about ready to go
off the edge. Ice melting in the Arctic
might be another one to think about. So,
mass extinctions. I've been asked before
whether or not the Earth has shown tipping
points. We know they happen in ponds. They
happen in small ecosystems. But mass
extinctions, in fact, can happen on a
planetary scale. We already saw this mass
extinction graphic. They're labeled there,
the Ordovician-Silurian, the Late
Devonian, the Permo-Triassic where we lost
95% of all the species on the planet. The
Triassic-Jurassic in the KT where we lost
dinosaurs and a lot of marine reptiles.
The point is, is that these are mass
extinctions, and you'll see in every case
there's a drop in diversity. This is
generic marine diversity.
So this is a marine record, not a
terrestrial one. But the point is, is that
when it recovers, and it takes
between 5 and 10 million years
for life to recover after
these mass extinctions,
life is completely different.
We've lost those organisms that
founded the diversity on the planet prior
to the extinction, and they don't come
back. So it reassembles. It is, in fact, a
new state. So the earth is warming
rapidly. You've seen many versions of
this. But I'm providing here a little bit
of a perspective about- from our
perspective. So, we're here on this
graphic. All of those different colored
squiggles show different scenarios.
Depending on what models are used by IPCC,
we will be here. Now, you've heard a lot
about the evolution of humans, modern
humans. By the time we get to that point,
in 2050, we will have global planetary
temperatures warmer than our species has
ever experienced on its time on earth. And
if we happen to make it to 2100, and to
temperatures somewhat above 4 degrees,
Earth has not been as hot as that
projected temperature in 14 million years.
Now the perspective is, and this is one
I'm giving you, mammal species don't live
that long. We don't have mammal species on
the planet that are 14 million years old.
So the memory of this climate, in the
genome of these species, is gone. World
population is still growing. Now, there
will be 9 billion people on the planet by
2045. So, 2045 here, there will be 9
billion people. And if we continue at-
these are current fertility rates shown
in the upper blue, current fertility
rates. You can imagine.
I mean, 15 million people on the planet.
Unbelievable. In fact, fertility rates are
slowing but not fast enough. Instead of
replacing ourselves, a male and a female,
with two children. We would have to go
down to just .5 children per person to
follow the lower blue curve. So human
population growth is the elephant in the
room. It is tremendously terrifying. So,
even though the Late Quaternary,
transition from a Pleistocene, the cold,
arid Pleistocene to the warmer more
wetter, Holocene is not exactly analogous
and, in fact, very different in many ways
to the kinds of climate we're experiencing
today. In fact, there are two similar
features. One, we are warming the
environment as we move from the
Pleistocene to the Holocene. And we're
also expanding. As humans, we're
colonizing the globe. So those two
features are, in fact, something we share
with what's happening today. So you heard
a little bit about these dramatic warming
and cooling events. Here's the
Bolling-Allerod and then followed by an
abrupt Younger Dryas. It's a cooling event
that saw the extinction, for example, of
Irish elk in Ireland as that environment
cooled rapidly. And then we end up into
what's called the Holocene or really about
the last 10,000 or so years of relatively
constant temperatures. However, we
expanded in this latter part of a
Quaternary. You know, we left Africa
around 200,000 years ago. We colonized
Europe and Asia. We colonized Australia
somewhere between 40 and 60,000 years ago.
And then we made it to the Americas last,
somewhere between 13 and 35,000 years ago.
Now, with our colonization of these
isolated areas, we caused extinctions.
This is a photo. This beautiful image is
the menagerie of animals that used to roam
in North America and are now
no longer here. There are
[[inaudible 00:08:04]] giant ground
sloths, glyptodons. There's the giant
bison. Camels which basically evolved in
North America left colonized Asia,
colonized South America and went extinct
in North America. And then horses which,
again, have millions of years of history
in North America and went extinct only to
be recolonized by Spanish explorers.
Historically, about half the world's large
animals, animals larger than 44 kilograms
or about 100 pounds, went extinct at this
time. Incidentally, humans are about that
size. So it's not just our impact that
cause change in animal distributions and
abundance. In fact, there are some small
mammals, like this bog leming that
went extinct at this Pleistocene, Holocene
transition. So we know that ice covered
much of Canada, and there was no place for
these bog lemings to live. Every one of
those black dots you see in North America
were occupied by bog lemings during the
Pleistocene. They're no longer found
really in the lower 48. In fact, what they
are- they're occupying this orange
range up here. They are really an
circumarctic species. So they responded as
you'd expect a species that likes a
relatively cold environment. As the ice
left, they tracked that environment
northwards. But not all species responded
that way. These are two images of two
species that are found in a cave called
Samwell Cave that excavated several years
ago in northern California, shown by the
black dot there. These two species didn't
really respond north. In fact, they
contracted their ranges to higher
elevation but also much wetter
environments that's currently found
in Samwell Cave today, which is located on
the shores of Lake Shasta. So these
animals- the mountain beaver, it's not
confined to mountains nor is it a beaver.
It is the last species of what was a very
large group of species in the family
aplodontiidae which is a very ancient,
North American family of rodents. And it
is the only species left in the family
today. It's very primitive, and it cannot
concentrate its urine. And so it has to be
by running fresh water all day, all the
time. And so you find them confined into
very dense old-growth Douglas fir forests
along the coast and the pacific northwest,
a very ancient lineage that is threatened
by warming temperatures and dry
conditions. The other animal you see is
the white-footed vole. Very little is
known about this animal accept the fact
that it's somewhat arboreal, and it's
found in deciduous trees and probably up
in these old-growth Doug fir forests.
This animal contracted with the Doug fir
forest of a wetter condition, not so much
higher up in elevation. Animals today are
moving pole-ward just like they did in the
Pleistocene. This is a range map of the
current distribution in 2013. The black
line is the current distribution of the
armadillo. The armadillo is related to
that glyptodon, that giant thing I showed
you in the previous slide. It's a South
American animal, and it is expanding. It
made it across the Rio Grande in 1850, and
it's expanding northward. It's limited by
winter temperatures. So if there are 24
freeze days or more, this animal can't
survive, it's young can't survive. And
what's happening is, as our North American
climates are warming, this animal is
progressively colonizing
further and further north. So what you
see, not the Xs but every other symbol on
this are instances where armadillos have
advanced beyond their 2013 static range.
Be interesting to know where they are
after this winter. However, the thing
about this that I want to point out, it's
not just that animals respond the way you
predict they would based on what we know
from fossils. But the other thing is, this
particular animal, the armadillo, is the
only mammal we know about in the world
that carries leprosy. And so this is an
example of these unexpected synergistic
things that can, in fact, impact humans in
ways we don't anticipate. Actually, they
got leprosy from us. Leprosy evolved in
Asia, most likely India. And they
contracted leprosy from us probably
somewhere around Louisiana. But this
animal can transmit leprosy to humans as
well. So, similarly to what I explained to
you about the mountain beaver and the
white-footed vole, animals will find their
proper environments. And so it's not just
that they move further north, they, as
warming conditions prevail and as drying
conditions prevail, they'll also move up
in elevation. So many of you might have
hear about the pikas. This is one of the
Asian species. There are, in fact, 28
Asian species of pikas. They're related to
rabbits and heirs. They're just the most
wonderful thing to work with. They have
this enormously interesting physiology.
They have a resting body temperature of
about 104 degrees, and they live really
high. In the Himalayas, they live above
15,000 feet. Now, the problem with- so
we've been studying these particular
animals all along the Himalayan front in
India and Nepal. And it turns out that
only some of these species can tolerate
the hypoxic conditions
that are characteristic of that high
elevation. So these particular animals
and, in fact, they've shown to be moving
up much more rapidly than American pikas
of which have moved up around 150 meters.
In the Himalayas, they've moved up, at
least, 1,000 meters. And they're pinched,
right, from above, because of those
hypoxic conditions and from below
from warming and also human
alteration of their environment. Now,
another kind of unexpected example, and,
again, to demonstrate just what ecosystems
mean in terms of how species are
connected. The map you see on the left is
a map of the distribution, on present, the
whitebark pine distribution in North
America. Whitebark pine is high elevation
pine. It's the last conifer until you get
to tree lines, so it's the thing that you
often see. It's krumholtz in the Rocky
Mountains. It's a five-needle pine, and it
has these really, really calorically rich
nuts in the cone. If we just look at
climate models for the distribution of the
whitebark pine and you can go to 2030,
2060, and 2090. You can see by 2090,
there's barely any whitebark pine left in
the lower 48. Now that projection was made
before we saw what happened with the
mountain pine beetle. For those of you
that have traveled anywhere in the Rocky
Mountains, you know that in the last
decade, conifer forests, all the way up to
tree line, have been desonated. In the
Yellow Stone region, in some of these
areas, whitebark pine are down 80%. This
is a photo from one of the high elevation
areas that I work in, in Yellow Stone. And
you can see a lot of standing dead trees.
Because the beetle is allowed to survive
over the winter. It's not killed off, it's
a native beetle. The climate is definitely
implicated in the expansion of this
beetle. It now goes all the way up to tree
line. It's not killed off. And it probably
reproduces several times per year instead
of having to recolonize every year. Well,
why is that? Why do I have a picture of a
grizzly bear? It turns out that the number
of whitebark pine cones in a tree is
directly correlated with over winter
survival of adult bears and their cubs.
And it's indirectly correlated with
problem bears the following summer. So
when there's not a lot, in some cases they
may it 40 to 50% of their fat as a result
of eating these middens of cones. They're
mostly, again, another player in this are
the Clark nutcrackers and the red
squirrels here. But these grizzly bears
need this to pack on the fat. And what
happens is they come out of hibernation
earlier, and they start getting into
trouble, looking for food in human
dwellings. So, again, an unanticipated and
kind of surprising but very major impact
from climate change. The other thing that
happens and these are data, I'm not
showing you the actual data. But during
the Pleistocene, Holocene transition,
there were lots of different small mammals
in the Samwell Cave site in northern
California I talked about. But the animal
that just took over that site is the deer
mouse, peromyscus maniculatus. And, in
fact, this animal has dominated the entire
Holocene assemblage. So the community
structure of small mammals changed. And
this is not due to human hunting, this is
due to the fact there are many more
disturbed environments in the Holocene.
This animal has very high intrinsic rates
of growth. They don't care what the
environment it. They don't mind if it's
just been burned. They don't mind if it's
the edge of a field or if it's an
old-growth forest. They like disturbance.
This animal is the most commonly trapped
small mammal in North America. So if you
lay a trap anywhere
outside of human habitation, you're likely
to catch this guy. It also tends to carry
a lot of diseases. So this is a witty
species and it thrives with human
environments. And the specialist species
are the ones that take a nose dive. Now
I'm sure there are some of you that are
gardeners here, and they don't consider
the pocket gophers as a particularly
favorable friend in their garden. But, in
fact, these guys took a hit at the end of
the Pleistocene. This is a pocket gopher,
it has fur lined cheek pouches, and it
stores its seeds and digs. And, in fact,
this is a specialist species. It is so
energetically expensive to live under
ground. It takes between 360 and 3,400
times the energy to do this than to move
the same distance above ground. This is,
by any accounts, a very specialist
species. So they decline. Humans are
directly causing the extinction of
animals. We are threatened to lose almost
a quarter of our species. I just read an
article that said about a third of our
bird species in Europe are threatened.
Most of these are from hunting. We're
about ready to see the loss of elephants
in the next decade or two. One out of
every twelve elephants was killed in just
the last three years. This is a crisis.
Fifty-one percent of humans of the
terrestrial land, has been co-opted for
human use. The only place that's left on
this map, that aren't show in purple, are
deserts and tropical forests. Those are
the least easily farmed land on the
planet, but they're also, in some ways,
especially the tropical forest, some of
the most important. Everywhere else, we
have made a mark. We have an extinction
debt, and we will lose a lot of
biodiversity in the near future.
I get asked a lot, "Can speciation
rescue biodiversity?"
Absolutely not. Species take between two
and five million years,
this is mammal
species, to evolve.
So, we can cause them to disappear in a
decade or two, but it takes millions of
years to accumulate the diversity we might
have lost. So how do we avoid this
planetary tipping point? We increased
energy conversion, obviously. We stole
habitat loss. We increase global
cooperation. This has got to be done
globally. And we stabilize population
growth. And, finally, how do you stabilize
population growth? I get asked what is the
most- in my opinion, the single most
important thing for us to do is to educate
women globally. And the reason is because
as education goes up, fertility rate goes
down. The more girls that are in school,
secondary school, the number of years is
really important, the more fertility rates
go down. And interestingly, GDP and
poverty rates also go up. Human innovation
is remarkable. We can see the origin of
the universe. I can't believe we can see
the origin of the universe. And we can see
ourselves in our beautiful planet from
space. Why can't we
avoid the next tipping point? Thank you.